[Music]
[Applause]
these Marcus Spears ESPN NFL analyst you
can see a Monday through Friday at 4
Eastern on NFL live with Dan orlovsky
meet at times Ryan Clark and of course
Laura Rutledge
how are you buddy
hey man
DP question yeah will you go send me one
of those little trinkets bro I didn't
ask you like three times what do you
want
I don't know send me send me the one you
like the most well no I wouldn't send
you the one I liked the most I'd send
you the one I like the least if you send
me the one you like the most I would I
would know how much I mean to you though
what are you gonna send me
I don't know we'll do an exchange it's
Christmas it's the given season so if
you send me something I'll send you
something back all right
uh I got to send you a picture of myself
so you can put back there by the
fireplace
how about a picture of you hitting
orlovsky on NFL Live I'll send you a
real live video on that I like that
running during breaks I'd love that glad
you pound his face here
um which which team is headed in the
right direction Colts or the Steelers
based off last night
fillers I believe
um I think Kenny Pickett took a step
forward last night DP especially making
that critical Drive uh to get in the end
zone making some really good throws and
you can see the rest of the team
starting to find that believability
um we you know he turned the football
over early which rookies do that's what
they do
um
but I think last night was like one of
those you know how we have these young
quarterbacks man and they had those
moments you kind of reflect back to if
they start playing well I think this
game you'll point to that
um
you know the the out route to fryer move
was a huge throw the confidence that he
had in George Pickens
um you see that kind of relationship
starting to evolve two young players
getting on the same page I I just think
uh I think right now even the one um
Deontay Dropped In The End Zone was a
really good throw
um I think right now you're starting to
see kind of a transition into him being
the guy and guys believing that they can
win with him at quarterback which in
turn does a lot for his mental and how
he goes about his job going forward
help me understand the situation with
Zach Wilson that Robert Sala said when
he's ready to roll yeah but he wasn't
injured on Sunday was he he was
interesting but he not ready he's not
ready man I said it last week when we
were on get up um he's not ready he
needs the mature more
um and and two you know this as well as
anybody you've been covering Sports
before I was born the New York Market is
fragile bro and when you make a mistake
like he did in that press conference by
saying he took no responsibility or
didn't feel responsible that mentally
for coaching staff and the other guys in
that locker room said hey man you might
need to sit down on the wall wow because
you don't understand right now the
magnitude of the job that you have and
that's fair like a second year
quarterback dealt with injuries his
rookie year dealt with injuries coming
into this season not understanding like
the responsibility and full totality of
a quarterback Beyond just playing the
actual position because he wasn't
playing well either like we can't make
an excuse he wasn't playing well and
then we see Mike White have the success
albeit against Chicago but still you see
him have success you see a better
operation from this offense and I think
now you just need growth and maturity
and maybe you do that from the sideline
watching other guys and Veterans play I
don't want people to get it misconstrued
Mike White is not the Savior okay he's
not gonna walk right in on the horse and
the New York Jets are going to do what
Nick Foles did with the Philadelphia
Eagles after Carson Wentz went out but I
do believe there is a maturity trait to
him and understanding that this is what
I need to do in order for this team to
have success as opposed to
um Zach really knowing that right now so
I think Robert Salah needs to stick with
Mike White until he does it and when
he's saying the the meaning of he's not
ready he's not ready maturity wise to
handle what he's being asked to do let
alone playing bad football
more likely to be a bust Zach Wilson or
Trey Lance
Zach Wilson
Zach Wilson and DP I remember coming out
of the draft okay
my first question was why is Justin
Fields not being considered for the sake
of picking this draft that's number one
Trey Lance has a little built-in
insulation because Kyle Shanahan is so
phenomenal at play calling that he can
hide a lot of those flaws uh I know a
lot of people have a lot of respect for
Mike leflore that's the offensive
coordinator with the New York Jets
um and what he's able to do I mean they
put up 300 plus yards with Mike White
last week so it's not offensively you
got weapons there from an offensive
standpoint I think Zach Wilson coming
out of BYU and I said this I said this
DP during the draft if you're going to
be the second overall pick
coming out of Brigham Young you need to
light the world on fire and I just
didn't feel like he did that
um coming out of there to be compared to
a quarterback like Trevor Lawrence
coming out of Clemson or compared to a
quarterback like Justin Fields coming
out of Ohio State and I know Justin
Fields probably got a little bit of a
bad taste because of previous Ohio State
quarterbacks I know that factored into
uh that decision Trey Lance didn't have
a lot of reps played at a small school
but Trey Lance was a a freak athlete
Superior running the ball with the ball
in his hands and I just thought Zach
Wilson was kind of a guy
um Zach Wilson to me does nothing better
than Daniel Jones
when it comes to arm strength when it
comes to athletic ability when it comes
to potentially being in the right system
and how you can be a really good
quarterback and the other thing DP he's
frail
he's a small guy yeah
um so it's not a I don't think outside I
mean he has a really good arm you can't
take that away from him but outside of
that there's nothing really dynamic
about Zach Wilson based on what we've
seen up until this point on the
professional level
I think the Packers front office wants
to play Jordan love yeah it's just a
delicate situation of how can we do this
and and have Aaron save face absolutely
and what we've learned over the last two
years with everything that's transpired
is that Aaron Rodgers is going to make
this decision look man DP I'm telling
you
this is one of those slippery slopes of
how much power do you give to the player
and the the Green Bay Packers and look
for us watching rightfully so right
two-time MVP is Aaron Rodgers one of the
greatest quarterbacks to ever played you
want to make him happy and make sure
he's good and where he is but you don't
do it to the you don't do a disservice
to your franchise in the future either
um based on you know this this was we
were already close to the end before he
signed the three-year contract we're
close to the end of his career or the
end of him being in Green Bay he told
you many times I don't know if I even
want to be there and then he came back
and recommitted and obviously this
season isn't going the way that they
hoped it would go but ultimately
at some point are you going to sit a
quarterback for five years
like is Joy love gonna sit for five
years there's no better time than right
now
for the Green Bay Packers to use
whatever the injury is or whatever the
pain Aaron Rodgers is in to say hey man
give us a couple weeks to let the young
fella play let you for like fully heal
up and see what we can do right you're
playing two opponents that you should be
able to beat even with Jordan love in
this in the lineup where you still
potentially could have that
mathematically uh possibility to get in
the playoffs let me give you a news
flash DP they ain't getting in the damn
plans okay nothing about this team that
told us they gonna run all four to five
next games if they do great it'll be a
great story for the NFL it ain't gonna
happen in my opinion but this would be a
great situation but Aaron Rodgers
controls that and they told us that two
years ago talking to Marcus Spears ESPN
NFL analyst former NFL player the
quarterback most likely to be with his
current team next year Tom Brady or
Aaron Rodgers
Aaron Rodgers because of the 50 million
I think Tom is going to call it quits
bro
um
DP should we remind everybody that Tom
Brady got 375 million dollars waiting on
him at Fox
or we all forgot about that so yeah but
he had that and he decided I mean he
decided that he was going to choose
football and he is learning that his
damn ego got in the way
that's what he learned because what
happened in Tampa
based on what he needs can happen next
year they can suffer injuries next year
new contracts guys move in places can
happen next year Tom Brady
who we consider the greatest of all time
and I think that's fair because of what
he's accomplished or what he's been able
to do
but right now at 45 BP as much as we
talk about his greatness
through for 5 000 yards last year he's
still got some gas left in the tank his
success is predicated on what's around
him let's not get it twisted okay
there's no coincidence that a couple
years ago LeBron James won a
championship because A.D was healthy and
a young player and ascended when you get
to a certain age when you get to a
certain point in your career and I'm not
saying quarterbacks are not dependent on
what's around them obviously we know
that but when you're 45 it's a little
bit more critical that your offensive
line is intact it's a little bit more
critical that you have a good run game
it's a little bit critical that you have
an offensive minded coach that can put
you in positions to be successful right
now it's a bunch of disarray in Tampa so
even if he decides to come back it's
Tampa the right place
we don't know that we don't know if
Leftwich is going to lead we don't know
if Todd Bowles is going to still be the
head coach we don't know any of that
there is nothing in Tampa right now
outside of if Tom says I want to come
back that's etched in stone so I think
he's gonna ride off in the sunset bro
Mark is good to talk to you sorry about
your uh LSU Tigers I know man you didn't
have to bring how do you lose to Texas A
M if he don't do it man don't do it
don't take me down this I already been
down this black hole don't do it to me
again man immature
immature
that's what it was
it was right there it was right there
for you you guys could have been in
there but you know I trust Dan orlowsky
saying LSU's overrated
Dan olowski went to Uconn and we can end
it on that all right fair enough
much love my brother thank you man
that's Mark Spears I like how you
started a beef I did there's no beef
there
Orlowski never said anything about Alex
you know they just threw it in there
he's walking down the hall right now
yeah where's our losskey come here I'll
show you overrated